[Musik]
Einigung in letzter Sekunde wie teuer
wird's für Deutschland das ist unser
Thema heute Abend und damit einen guten
Abend liebe Zuschauer Christian Lindner
wollte die Schuldenbremse nicht
aussetzen die SPD keine Sozialleistungen
kürzen und die Grünen keine
klimasubventionen hergeben fast hätte es
die Ampel zerlegt nach vier Wochen
dramatischem regierungsstreit sollen
jetzt Kürzungen und höhere Abgaben die
17 Milliarden einspielen die fehlen für
alle wird heizen und Autofahren teurer
der CO2 Preis steigt schneller und
stärker als geplant und sonst noch wie
teuer wird's fürs Land das fragen wir
uns und diese Gäste die Vorsitzende von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Ricarda
lang Christian dir Fraktionsvorsitzender
der
FDP der CDU
haushaltsausschussvorsitzende Helge
braun die Journalistin Christina
Dunz Herr Josef Tenhagen Chefredakteur
finanztip und Sarah Tacke Leiterin der
ZDF Redaktion Recht und
Justiz sie sind zu Gast bei Maybritt ner
begrüßt alle Gäste noch mal
ausgesprochen herzlich eigentlich hatte
man sich vorgenommen dass es keine
Nachtsitzung mehr geben soll die
Einigung im Haushaltsstreit gab es am
Mittwoch Morgen um
5R Auftritt nach 12 Stunden nonstop verh
die drei von der Ampel fühlen sich alle
als Sieger der
haushaltsrangeleien wir stärken den
sozialen Zusammenhalt sie sorgen für
Impulse für die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität und Erneuerung weil die
Orientierung an der Schuldenbremse für
uns weiter von großer Bedeutung ist
jetzt wird kräftig gespart umgeschichtet
und der Bürger zur Kasse gebeten Strom
Gas tanken überall wird der stärker
steigende CO2 Preis spürbarzu Z kommen
eine Kerosinsteuer für Inlandsflüge für
die Bauern wird Agrardiesel teurer eine
Eskalation im ukrainekrieg würde die
Koalition allerdings anders finanzieren
um vorbereitet zu sein haben wir bereits
miteinander vereinbart in einer solchen
Lage dem Bundestag einen
überschreitensbeschluss vorzuschlagen
für die Opposition klingt das verdächtig
nach einer neuen Schuldenbremsen
Hintertür es ist eine
vorhersehbare Notlage die sie spätestens
zur Mitte des Jahres erklären werden
müssen und dann wollen sie uns in
Anspruch nehmen noch einmal für die
Überschreitung der verschuldensgrenze
des Grundgesetzes diesen Trick lassen
wir Ihnen nicht durchgehen Herr
Bundeskanzler da wird von Hintertüren
gesprochen aber erstmal Christina Dunz
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland hat
Christian Lindner sich durchgesetzt es
bleibt bei der Schuldenbremse sie wird
nicht noch mal ausgesetzt wie groß ist
die Unruhe bei den Sozialdemokraten bei
den Grünen bei denzi Sozialdemokraten
war sie am Mittwoch sehr groß weil man
den Kanzler ja so verstanden hatte und
auch bei dem Parteitag so verstehen
konnte dass die Belastung die durch die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine auf
Deutschland zukommen werden ein guter
Grund sind eine Notlage zu erklären und
jetzt könnte man sagen er hat sich nicht
gegen seinen Finanzminister durchgesetzt
Herr Bundeskanzler ist oder Olaf Scholz
ist Bundeskanzler Christian Lindner
regiert im Moment insofern würde ich
sagen der Punkt geht kurzfristig an den
Parteichef langfristig der parteisf der
FDP langfristig glaube ich kommt es als
Bumerang zurück wir haben gesehen in den
Ländern bei den Wahlen hat die FDP sehr
stark verloren sie hat nur zwei Punkte
Schuldenbremse einhalten keine Steuern
erhöhen und es wird anders kommen und
insgesamt würden Sie sagen dass der
Crash dieser Koalition schon wiah war
und ist er jetzt nur aufgeschoben das
haben sie im Grunde schon angedeutet
also das was zu hören war aus der SPD
war dass äh der Finanzminister quasi dem
Bundeskanzler die Pistole auf die Brust
setzt und sagt ich weiche hier nicht ich
will die Schuldenbremse nicht aussetzen
jedenfalls das jetzt nicht ankündigen
und er hatte dann also der Bundeskanzler
hatte dann nur die Wahl friss oder stirb
Herr Lindner ist ja auch etwas früher
aus diesen Verhandlungen herausgegangen
die beiden anderen habbeck und Scholz
blieben sitzen und haben sich dann
letztendlich dazu durchgerungen dazu
erstmal ja zu sagenh Herr D jetzt müssen
sie Fraktionschef der Liberalen kurz
erklären das war eine Pistole auf der
Brust des Bundeskanzlers weil sie diese
Umfrage fürchten die sie unter den
fdpmgliedern machen und nee aber die ist
ja eigentlich nicht bindend da stehen
sie drüber alsoin es geht doch darum in
vernünftigen Haushalt aufzustellen und
sich ans Grundgesetz zu halten das
Verfassungsgericht hat noch mal deutlich
gemacht wie die Schuldenbremse
umzusetzen ist und wir haben keine
besondere Notlage für das Haushaltsjahr
2024 gesehen und deswegen ist es auch
richtig die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten
wir haben ja bei coronazazeit gesehen
dass da Geld für alles mögliche da war
damit hören wir auf und ich will
hinzufügen Frau inner was mich wirklich
freut auch Teil dessen was vereinbart
worden ist dass wir trotzdem die
steuerlichen Entlastungen nicht bei der
Einkommensteuer also für die arbeitende
Mitte im kommenden Jahr bekommen das ist
immerhin für eine
Durchschnittsfamilie zwei mundmüter und
Feder die Arbeiten und zwei Kinder über
500 € im Jahr Entlastung wir haben
Belastung bei der CO2 Bepreisung das
stimmt das ist der Faht ja der wird
wieder aufgenommen was die große
Koalition schon beschlossen hatte
Belastung aber wenn man netto
drunterzieht dann wird eine Familie
damitte in Deutschland richtigerweise
entlastet also die die arbeitenon wieder
die inhaltliche Kurve bekommen hätte der
Bundesfinanzminister diese Regierung
springen lassen um den Preis auf gar
keinen Fall die Schuldenbremse noch mal
auszusetzen nein chr hat ja frühzeitig
gesagt dass er nicht sieht dass man die
Schuldenbremse noch mal aussetzen könnte
und dass es dafür weder eine
verfassungsrechtliche noch eine
politische Begründung die Grünen und die
Sozialdemokratie ein bisschen es ist
kein Geheimnis das kann man glaube ich
offen sagen dass es zwischen den
Parteien im Deutschen Bundestag eine
unterschiedlich Haltung zur
Schuldenbremse gibt die FDP ist da klar
aufgestellt Herrn Brauen denke hat sich
ja 2021 schon sehr kritisch zur
Schuldenbremse geäußert viele CDU
Ministerpräsidenten wir haben da eine
klare Haltung und einen Satz noch die
Schuldenbremse ist ja kein selbstfck
sondern die schützt zukünftige
Generation vor Belastungen und das ist
mir wichtig und deswegen geht's darum
auch Steuererhöhung Zukunft zu verhind
jetzt die Bürger dafür ist natürlich
eine der wichtigen Fragen dieser Sendung
Ricard lang ist gleich dran und wir
zitieren vorher noch mal ein Wort des
Kanzlers eine Woche nach der
Urteilsverkündung wandte sich der
Kanzler im Deutschen Bundestag an seine
Bürger die Bürger und Bürger können
darauf vertrauen dass der Staat seine
Zusagen ihnen gegenüber einhält in ihrem
Alltag hier und heute ändert das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
nichts sagt der Bundeskanzler odlaf
Scholz jetzt kommen neue Belastungen auf
die Bürger zu im Grunde hat sich die
Ampel geeinigt darauf dass in
allererster Linie die Bürger diese 17
Milliarden zahlen und ein Teil der
Industrie diese 17 Milliarden Zahlen
Frau lang hat der Bundeskanzler sein
Wort gebrochen nein das war natürlich
ein etwas großes Wort zu sagen es gibt
gar keine Änderung im Alltag aber WN man
sich anschauen muss was konkret passiert
wenn wir z.B CO2 Preis anschauen gehen
wir zurück auf den pfahr der bereits von
der großen Koalition vorgesehen war
damals war vorges ohne Entlastung wir
haben jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren m
tief Entlastung auf den Weg gebracht
Herr D hat gerade welche angesprochen
wenn es um die einkommenenssteuer geht
durch die Abschaffung der eegumlage
zahlen wir 85% von dem was über den CO2
Preis reinkommt zurück an die Menschen
und an die Bürger und es gibt z.B mit
der Senkung der Stromsteuer auch
Entlastung für die Unternehmen im Land
und gleichzeitig haben wir in den
letzten Wochen massive Angriffe auf den
Sozialstaat erlebt auf die
Kindergrundsicherung auf das Bürgergeld
und die konnten abgewandt werden wir
stehen weiter ich spreche vor allem von
Friedrich Merz der sesagt hat weg damit
weg damit das würden wir alles sofort
abschaffen und das konnten wir
verhindern wir stehen zum Bürgergeld wir
stehen vor allem auch zur
Kindergrundsicherung die unverändert
kommen kann das heißt damit geben wir
gerade Menschen mit einem kleinen
Einkommen und auch mit einem kleinen
geldbottel Sicherheit im Land woll sie
muten das werden wir gleich noch
besprechen sie muten den Menschen
tatsächlich an vielen Stellen etwas zu
auch die gastpreisbremsen werden
ausgesetzt es werden die Mehrwertsteuer
bei gastr steigen es kommen jetzt eben
auch die höheren CO2 Preise dazu
und das was man sich natürlich fragt
das alles um diese ampfel
zusammenzuhalten Frau lang wenn Sie das
Gefühl haben dass es eigentlich auch
eine andere Lösung gegeben hätte nämlich
dafür zu kämpfen dass die Notlage noch
mal erklärt wird und die Schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt K da müssen wir einmal
unterscheiden bei der Notlage haben wir
ganz konkret über die Ukraine gesprochen
und das sagen wir auch weiterin wir
finanzieren jetzt die
Ukrain FL werden wir es auch finanzieren
dass ich grundsätzlich für eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse Streit das ist so
weil meiner sich das ein Zeichen der
Generation Gerechtigkeit wäre wenn die
Älteren in das investieren was den
jüngeren Freiheit gibt aber am Ende
finde ich es auch ein Wert dass diese
Ampel in der Lage sich zu einigen denn
ich würde es mal umdrehen wenn ich jetzt
gerade sitzen würde und wir hätten diese
Woche keine Einigung gefunden würden sie
mich wahrscheinlich fragen Frau lang wie
kann es denn sein dass da niemand mal
sein Schatten springt warum sind sie
nicht mal ein bisschen pragmatisch man
muss doch in der Lage sein sich zu
einigen genau das jetzt vier Wochen lang
in dem Moment wo man sich geeinigt hat
heißt es Frau lang warum sind da nicht
nur grüne Punkte drin Herr D warum sind
nicht nur FDP Punkte drin ich glaube
übrigens von diesem wer ist der Gewinner
wer ist der Verlierer mal wegkommen s
Land Stabilität wir sind ja schwer
inhaltlich und Fragen auf wessen Kosten
findet diese Einigung jetzt statt
Herrmann Josef Tenhagen ist bei uns
Chefredakteur von Finanztest Herr
Tenhagen ist finanztipp bitte
Tipp ganz korrekt wir testen nicht den
finanztipp sondern wir haben den Chef
von finanztip hier Herr ten sie sind
helfen uns bei der Beantwortung der
Frage ob auf ein Vertrag zu Lasten
Dritter geschlossen wurde also
so hat es Herr Lindemann formuliert von
der CDU das müssen sie jetzt nicht im
Munde so führen das ist ja noch eine
freundliche Formulierung der Bürger wird
ausbaden was die Ampel vorher
verschlampert hatte na ja also die Frage
ist einfach der Bürger muss mehr
bezahlen so ist das verschlampert worden
ich würde sagen da ist so ein dreifaches
Unentschieden rausgekommen nichts ist
richtig vorangegangen aber am Schluss
muss es irgendwie bezahlt werden und
dann hat man unterschiedliche Wege
gesucht um es zu bezahlen und das was
diese Woche verabschiedet worden ist ist
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht der
große Punkt der große Punkt ist
tatsächlich das Gesamtbild da wird im
Augenblick sind die Energiepreise noch
hoch da wird die energiepreisbremsen
werden zum Jahresende abgeschafft das
ist bei Gaskunden ein richtiges Problem
bei Leuten mit Fernwärme womöglich ein
noch größeres Problem da sind die Preise
im Augenblick im Durchschnitt doppelt so
hoch wie das was die Preisbremse sagt
dann kommt die Frage der
Mehrwertsteuererhöhung beim Gas und dann
kommen die CO2 Abgaben dazu und all das
zusammen macht dann teureere Rechnung W
wenn man jetzt nur die die Entscheidung
dieser Woche nimmt dann kostet das 15 €
oder 20 € mehr für ein Sprit im Jahr das
kostet 20 € mehr fürs Heizöl oder 30en
wir nachher noch mal V ven was das dann
auch für eine einzelne Familie bedeutet
bei uns ist der ehemalige
kanzamtsminister so haben wir ihn noch
in Erinnerung lange ist er tatsächlich
das mittlerweile nicht mehr und leitet
jetzt den Haushaltsausschuss Herr Braun
das tun sie mit ganzer Kraft und waren
nicht nur in diesen letzten vier Wochen
natürlich bei allem mit dabei sondern
können jetzt auch mal ganz formal sagen
steht denn jetzt dieser Haushalt in
ihren Augen oder ist da noch irgendwas
nicht ordentlich um ihn zu verabschieden
also da sind noch sehr sehr viele
Probleme wir kennen ja bisher sozusagen
nur eine mündliche politische Einigung
wir kennen noch nicht irgendwie mal eine
konkrete Aufschlüsselung z.B die
Deutsche Bahn soll Privatisierungserlöse
erhalten was welches Tafel selber wollen
wir denn jetzt verkaufen ist das
sinnvoll das jetzt zu verkaufen kennt ja
jeder wenn man in der Not etwas verkauft
dann verkauft man es vielleicht nicht
zum besten Preis da sind noch sehr viele
Probleme äh vor denen wir stehen und äm
dazu kommt ähm dass auch manche
Buchungen gar nicht nachvollziehbar sind
plötzlich sollen nächstes Jahr mehr
Menschen in Arbeit gebracht werden als
das bisher der Fall war dem steht aber
gar keine Maßnahme gegenüber bei der
Einsparung im Bürgergeld und insofern
ähm glaube ich wenn man sich anschaut da
sind ein paar
buchungstricks verbunden eben mit
Belastungen der Bürger aber dass die bei
sich selber irgendwo mal gespart hätte
weniger Personal in den Ministerien oder
so auch schon mal um da ein Zeichen zu
setzen da sehe ich gar nichts würden die
Kollegen ihrer Fraktion noch mal klagen
Herr Braun also darum ging es ja auch
recht lange und recht ausführlich das
vermieden werden will und soll dass
dieser Haushalt noch mal nicht
verfassungsfest ist also rechtlich nicht
hinreichend klar ist sehen Sie eine
solche Gefahr wenn wir darüber reden
dass wir Kürzungen und mehrusgaben an
unterschiedlichen Stellen im Haushalt
haben das wäre kein Klagegrund wenn aber
die Schuldenbremse noch mal in der
notlagenerklärung ausgesetzt werden
würde für Dinge die schon zurückliegen
die schon bekannt sind oder die der Höhe
nach dafür ungeeignet sind muss man klar
sagen die Union steht nicht dafür zur
Verfügung dass man egal um welchen guten
Zweck zu erreichen gegen das Grundgesetz
verstößt und äh jetzt wird immer gesagt
die Amp hat sich entschieden die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten wir haben
eigentlich gerade zwei Themen wo immer
angedeutet wird mit neuen begriffen dass
man möglicherweise die Schuldenbremse
aussetzt ganz konkret schon eben was
die die die Lösung des atteils angeht
dazu kann ich nur sagen dass wir das
machen steht außer Frage Flutopfer W
auch das machen ist klar aber dass wir
wegen 2,6 Milliarden bei einer
jährlichen verschuldungsmglichkeit von
14 eine notlageus halt ich für völlig
absurd so aber formal hat natürlich
Christian Lindner jetzt erstmal zu
verbuchen oder kann verbuchen dass diese
Schuldenbremse eingehalten wird oder
kann er das eigentlich nicht und hat er
damit den K erpresst damit der nicht zu
ihnen überläuft der Herr Lindner ich ich
ich weiß nicht wie die das die drei das
untereinander
besprochen haben aber eigentlich kann
man doch nur seriös sagen wenn ein
irgendwann in Zukunft eine unerwartete
neue große Notlage Eintritt aus welchem
Grund auch immer dafür ist das
Grundgesetz da im Augenblick gibt es
überhaupt keinen Grund
eine Notlage zu erklären aber der
Kanzler hat gleich in seiner ersten Rede
zwei Gründe genannt einen den er sich
auf der Zeitachse vorstellen kann und
einen den er sich sogar sofort
vorstellen kann insofern ist für mich
die Frage ob die Schuldenbremse steht
oder nicht in der Ampel überhaupt nicht
klar aber darf ich da einmal noch mal
nachfragen weil wir haben ich würde auch
nachfragen weil es ist ja wichtig zu
verstehen ob sie nicht eigentlich immer
noch wie auch ihre beiden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Frau lang sagen
wir kämpfen weiter um ein eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse und unterstützen den
Kanzler da auch ja natürlich kämpfen
weiter für eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse das ist doch klar wenn
man nicht wenn man sich auf einen
Kompromiss innerhalb einer Regierung eig
plötzlich einen gemeinsamen
Parteitagsbeschluss hat sonder natürlich
sind wir drei unterschiedliche Parteien
mit drei unterschiedlichen Positionen
und ich bin der Meinung was wir jetzt
hinbekommen haben ist eine löhnosung die
funktioniert für 2024 wir schaffen es
das weiter in Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
investiert wird wir schaffen es dass
Klimaschutz nicht nachlassen und den
sozialen Zusammenhalt erhalten aber wenn
ich langfristig schaue auch nach ch der
nächsten Bundestagswahl will ich dass
die Schuldenbremse reformiert wird und
wir eine stärkere Trennung von
konsumtiven Ausgaben machen also denen
die einfach laufen und investien wo wir
wirklich in öffentliches Vermögen
investieren in unsere Bildung in unsere
Wirtschaft in die
Klimaneutralität sie das anders aber wir
werden im nächsten Bundestagswahlkampf
auch gegeneinander antreten mit
unterschiedlichen Position ich ein noch
Ukraine Sache weil W ich da schon
nachfragen würde weil wir haben ja klar
gesagt wir stehen an der Seite Ukraine
die Union hat das auch immer wieder klar
gesagt auch ein Demokrat wert finde ich
in diesem Land dass alle demokratischen
Parteien das in aller Klarheit sagen
dann kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen
dass in einem Moment wo die Situation in
der Ukraine verändern würde wo wir noch
mal deutlich mehr Gelder brauchen als
das was wir gerade haben die Union
tatsächlich sagen würde dazu sind wir
nicht bereit das zu
finanzieren wenn Olaf Scholz plötzlich
so ein wding einführt wir reden von
einem überschreitungsbeschluss ich gucke
ins Grundgesetz das kennt das
Grundgesetz überhaupt
überschreitensbeschlussbeschluss es ist
etwas wo man den Eindruck hat dass
diejenigen die gerade vom
Verfassungsgericht in dreifacher Weise
dem Verfassungsbruch überführt worden
sind nach neuen Wegen suchen
niedrigschwelliger möglicherweise als
das das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil
vorsieht wieder zusätzliche Schulden zu
machen und das muss man jetzt mal klar
sagen die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes auf der Bundesebene sieht
vor dass man zum einen strukturell sich
sogar Verschulden kann das sind über 13
Milliarden in im kommenden Jahr dass man
darüber hinaus wegen der konjunkturellen
Schwäche sich um weitere 2,6 Milliarden
Verschulden kann und das muss angesichts
von Rekord Steuereinnahmen reichen und
man kann auch nicht sagen dass alle
Krisen die wir erleben auf Dauer neben
dem Kernhaushalt finanziert werden
können sondern man muss mit der neuen
Realität Leben und wir haben hohe
Steuereinnahmen wir haben sehr sehr eine
sehr sag mal Schuldenbremse die auch
Spielraum gibt und mehr darf man zu dem
jetzigen Zeitpunkt mit aller Kenntnis
was wir heute über den ukraineekonflikt
kennen und was wir heute an
wir kommen darauf noch mal zurück es ist
tatsächlich ja jetzt schon das Reden
über eine neue Notlage also das
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse darauf hat
sich ja nun die Ampel aber erstmal nicht
verständigt wir versuchen noch mal ganz
kurz zurückzukehren zu dem Frau Dunz was
jetzt entschieden ist und beschlossen
ist für 24 da wird es erstmal diese CO2
Preiserhöhung geben
es wird Steuern geben die die FDP
eigentlich immer ausgeschlossen hat also
zusätzliche Steuererhöhungen oder
Abgaben
mhmel diese plastiksteuer von der Manau
ich gar nicht wusste dass die mal vom
Staat bezahlt wurde und weil de weil
Deutschland die EU Regeln noch nicht
eingehalten hat muss der Staat das
bezahlen weil wir das noch nicht
umgesetzt haben will ich fragen W das
wer das nicht anggesetzt hat
aber echter entbürokratisierungsbeitrag
wir werden erleben wenn das umgesetzt
wird was wird da für eine neue schon
wieder noch mal die Frage und eben CO2
steuerbepreisung und schon wieder hat
man dabei die Entlastung der Bürger
vergessen oder stimmt diese
Argumentation von Frau lang zu sagen das
was wir den Bürgern da ansonsten geben
ist schon so viel dass diese wenn auch
stärkere Erhöhung des CO2 Preises jetzt
eigentlich schon kompensiert ist und
schon mit drin ist oder sagen Sie nee
man hat jetzt bei den CO2 Preisen gehört
ja eigentlich immer das klimageld dazu
man hat schon wieder die soziale
Abfederung vergessen zumindest fehlt
dieses Signal also ich glaube nicht dass
die bürgerinen und Bürger das so
verstehen wie Frau lang das gerade
erklärt hat dass sie am Ende unterm
Strich gutbei rausgehen werden sondern
es wäre ein Signal gewesen dieses
klimageld was ja im Koalitionsvertrag
steht allerdings zeitlich nicht
definiert insofern ist das sehr
schwammig aber wenn man ähm aus dem
Fehler äh des Prozesses des
heizungsgesetzes gelernt hätte dass man
sagt wir haben eine Belastung aber die
die von denen wir glauben dass sie das
nicht bezahlen können oder dass ihnen
auch 15 € weh tun äh sie haben gerade so
pauschal gesagt 15 € mehr Sprit das ist
ja immer ganz kommt ja immer ganz drauf
an wer jeder ja aber das ist ja das kann
man doch überhaupt nicht verallgemeinern
jedenfalls ein Signal zu setzen dass
diese Menschen entlastet werden und
dieses klimageld ist so gut wie weg also
ich habe jetzt nicht in der Koalition
gehört dass man das ernsthaft versucht
bis 19 bis 225
noch in Gang zu setzen und das wäre
zumindest ein Signal gewesen auf an
gleicher Stelle oder zu gleicher Zeit zu
entlassen gleiche Frage mich nicht mehr
auf den Platz wen ich das sagen fr
müssen aber noch sitzen bleiben ja weil
nachdem was was her braun gerade gesagt
hat nicht noch mal zu Ukraine da komm
ich will gar zu Ukraine ich will zu der
Frage B und Entlastung was sagen weil
das wirklich wichtig ist wir haben
bereits beschlossen für den kommenden
Haus nicht noch mal aufzählen was sie
alles getan haben do fr das ist deshalb
wichtig weil der Eindruck entstehen
könnte dass hier übermäßig belastet wird
das exakte Gegenteil ist richtig 15
Milliarden EUR Entlastung nein ich will
ich will einach Zahlen darstellen weil
ich glaube wenn man so so virtuell
diskutiert dann kann dasin Zuschauer
nachvollziehen 15 Milliarden Euro für
die arbeitende Mitte 6 Milliarden Euro
für das Wachstum chancengesetz was
bedauerlicherweise zurzeit noch ich
hoffe das ändert sich von der Union im
Bundesrat aufgehalten wird damit mehr
investiert wird in Deutschland und
weitere 3 Milliarden Euro 3 Milliarden
Euro für das produzierende Werb also
echte steuerliche Entlastung im
kommenden Jahr und jetzt reden wir davon
priserhöhung CO2 Preiserhöhung
die
ensch das klimageld W ich lese ihren
Chef vor schweigen sie sekean lind CO2
Preiserhöhung stärkere Erhöhung des CO2
Preises im Juli dieses Jahres schon mal
richtig blöd und sagte wer daüber eine
Erhöhung nachdenke solle die
konjunkturelle Entwicklung nicht
vergessen und solle den Zusammenhang mit
der gesamtgesellschaftlichen Entwicklung
nicht
ver auch dank der besseren
Haushaltspolitik dieser Koalition ist
jetzt zum Glück die Inflation wieder
nach unten gegangen und nein Herr Braun
da brauchen sie nicht lachen weil da
müssen wir jetzt wirklich auch ernsthaft
mal drüber reden ganz konkret das was
beim CO2 Preis in zwischen Robert
habbeck Olaf Scholz und Christi lner
beschlossen worden ist ist das was die
große Koalition von Herr
braunst längst beschlossen hat ich will
nur das will nur das Gesamtkonzept
darstellen also wir haben wenn wir uns
ein Haushalt anschauen ich habe das
vorhin schon gesagt eine arbeitende
Familie der Mitte wird über 500 €
steuerlich entlast mehr von et 100€gesam
beim
co2is gleich ich wollte jetzt mal zeigen
was Check 24 ausgerechnet hat und andere
Portale wie hoch die Belastung für eine
vierköpfige
Famil
einöp mit Gaskosten von
2167 € brutto durch die höhere CO2
Abgabe das Ende der Preisbremse später
auch einer steigenden Mehrwertsteuer
allerdings geringerer Netzentgelte geht
man von insgesamt 370 € Mehrkosten fürs
kommende Jahr aus die Stromkosten werden
für dieses Jahr auf
1827 € geschätzt hier schlagen das Ende
der Preisbremse und höhere Netzentgelte
zu Buche hieße noch mal 155 EUR mehr im
kommenden Jahr so Kopf rechnen leicht
gemacht es sind auch über 500 € die
gleich wieder raus da ist der Sprit noch
nicht dabei ich wollte es gerade sagen
also werden jetzt natürlich Dinge
durcheinander gemischt von dem was
bereits beschlossen worden ist in der
Vergangenheit und das was jetzt in der
Nacht rausgekommen ist aber ich will
noch mal weil Herr Braun so nonchalant
gesagt hat die Ampel würde nicht bei
sich selbst schwen die Wahrheit der
Braun ist anders als die große Koalition
haben wir schon zu Beginn der
Wahlperiode einen automatischen
personalabbauschlüssel geschlossen im
Haushalt das automatisch Personal
reduziert wird das kann von Ihnen das
kam von er bauen ein Personal auf viicht
im Zusammenhang darstellen darf das kam
von ihnen nie wir werden jetzt
beispielsweise beim Bürgergeld sagen ja
wir stehen zum sozialstad keine Frage
aber gleichzeitig für Totalverweigerer
also die sie sich auch der
Zusammenarbeit mit der Arbeitsagentur
verweigern da werden wir
reduzieren wie gr wie groß dieser Anteil
ist doch überhaupt nicht messbar bisher
also die Agentur geht ja schon von
Zahlen dabei aus aber der Punkt ist mit
nichten ist es so als ob hier nicht auch
gespart wird und genau hingeschaut wird
und noch mal
ich ger Zusammenhang und will noch mal
einen Satz sagen weil dann über die
Schuldenbremse eben gesprochen worden
ist ich kenne aktuell nicht einen
unionsministerpräsidenten der aktiv
gesagt hat so wie es meine Partei tut
wir stehen zur Schuldenbremse her Braun
hat selbst in der letzten Wahlperiode
die Schuldenbremse in Frage gestellt des
tu ich nein deswegen tue ich mir soll
ich ihn das Zitat noch mal vor gerne
offkundig nicht gelesen ich hab ich habe
mir das im Vorfeld der Sendung einfach
noch mal rausgesucht weil mir wichtig
war genau zu schauen was sie seiner Zeit
gesagt
haben und der Satz lautete die
Schuldenbremse die Schuldenbremse ist in
den kommenden Jahren auch bei ansonsten
strenger Haushaltsdisziplin nicht
einzuhalten das ist fast mit Ansage
gewesen seiner
Zeiten und deshalb sage ich Ihnen jetzt
mal folgendes das ist jetzt auch erlaubt
erstens als als wir gemeinsam das
Bundeswehr Sondervermögen gemacht haben
warum haben wir das getan wir haben 100
Milliarden neben der regulären
Schuldenbremse warum weil wir nicht in
der Lage waren das innerhalb des
normalen Haushalts abzubilden da hat ihr
Minister persönlich gesagt der
helgebraun hatte recht wir haben einen
anderen Weg gewählt als den den ich
vorgeschlagen hab aber seitdem können
sie sich das Thema wirklich sparen das
zweite ist wenn sie sagen die CO2
Bepreisung wäre etwas da gehen sie jetzt
auf den Pfad der alten Regierung was sie
momentan machen ist sie haben in den
letzten Monaten der Bevölkerung gesagt
wir senken die Energiepreise wir helfen
euch wir machen eine energiepreisbremse
und die Menschen haben darauf vertraut
dann sind sie schon weil sie sich im
ersten Entwurf Haushalt 24 nicht leicht
einigen konnten haben sie dann schon die
energiepreisbremse wieder eingesammelt
und haben verschiedene Dinge erhöht und
jetzt kommen sie am 15 dezember und
sagen am 1.1 steigt die CO2 Bepreisung
noch mal die Grundidee der CO2
Bepreisung ist nicht viel Geld
einzunehmen die Grundidee der CO2
Bepreisung ist zu sagen auf lange Sicht
steigen die Kosten damit ich bei meinen
langfristigen Investitionen in ein Auto
oder eine Heizung Entscheidung treffen
kann aber sie nutzen das Instrument um
den Haushalt
zu vor das wäre sol CO2 Preisgeld wird
in festhalten den KTF gehen der wird
finanzieren was zu wenig jetzt in diesem
berühmten
klimatransformationsfond liegt da sagen
manche Journalistenkollegen das sei die
Schmuckschatulle von ck dagegen werrt er
sich natürlich das sind große
Subventionen für die Industrie das sind
Gelder die Innovation und Investitionen
anstoßen sollen in der Wasserwirtschaft
und anderes mehr diese Unterstützung von
stahlgrün machen von Intel von RWE grün
machen die gibt es weiter für die
richtig großen und hier ist jetzt noch
mal Beine Frage aber bei den Bürgern
sparen Sie und vergessen das klimageld
also erstmal würde ich sagen der CO2
Preis wird schon jetzt durch 85% über
die EEG Umlage war zurückgezahlt
zweitens sie haben recht das klimageld
die wurde abgeschaffen und das sind
ungefähr die Kosten also wir rechnen
jetzt von 12,4 Milliarden die reinkommen
durch die Erhöhung des CO2 Preis oder
insgesamt durch den CO2 Preis und ca
10,3 Milliarden kostet die abschaffende
der EEG Umlage das ist konkret eine
Verbesserung bei den Bürgern und bei den
Unternehmen ich teile aber den Punkt den
Sie gesagt haben Frau Dunz das kommt
signalmäßig sehr wenig an und ist für
mich auch wichtig wir halten weiter fest
am klimageld wir brauchen einen
auszahlmechanismus ich hoffe dass der so
schnell wie möglich kommt und ich will
auch dass dann so das S nicht
funktioniert nicht sononder der wird
irgendwann funktionieren und er wird
hoffentlich kommen dass schnell möglich
ausgezahlt wird ich verwre mich aber
wirklich dagegen dass man so tut als ob
der Klima und transformationsfor das
wärden irgendwie ein paar grüne
Spielprojekte ein paar grüne
lieblingsprojekteum geht die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
wira Infrastruktur es geht um
Arbeitsplätze und bei diesen
Arbeitsplätzen da geht's auch um soziale
Existenzen ich nehme das Beispiel sstah
ang en da war Robert habck diese Woche
dort und hat klar gesagt die Gelder
kommen weiterhin das heißt grüner Stahl
wird in Zukunft nicht in China
produziert nicht in USA produziert oder
auch dort aber er wird vor allem auch in
Deutschland produziert und dann sieht
man die Gesichter der Arbeitnehmer dort
und für die ist das kein da passiert
irgendwie nette Unterstützung von dem
Unternehmen sondern da hängen Familien
dran da häen Existenzen dran da häen
hängt Ängste und Träume dran und des
finde ich es absolut richtig dass wir
sagen die zentralen Projekte aus dem KTF
werden fortgeführt wir stärken uns in
Wirtschaftsstandort wir sichern ab
plätze und wir sorgen auch dafür dass
Deutschland international im Wettrennen
mit den USA mit chinaä wird heftig
diskutiert und es ist jetzt bei diesen
Diskussionen um den Haushalt auch
diskutiert worden ob 10 Milliarden für
Intel nicht die spitzenfirmer wenn es
eben um diese produktchips geht
angemessen sind und auf der anderen
Seite klagt der Mittelstand und klagen
die kleinen Firmen dass sie mit einer
Stromerhöhung von wenigstens 20% rechn
im neuen Jahr das sind die Netzentgelte
weil wenn die Netz
sind das 3,3 Cent über ein Daumen
gepeilt pro Kilowattstunde und wenn der
Mittelständler Unternehmen wenig für den
Strom bezahlt weil sie häufig weniger
bezahlen als wir Privatverbraucher dann
sind 3,3 Cent ein ordentlicher Schluck
aus der Pulle dann kann das schon mal 15
oder 20% sein also da die Frage die
großen schützen wir die großen sind die
Signalwirkungen und der Mittelstand die
kleinen Industrien beschweren sich das
stimmt so nicht ganz also es stimmt dass
wir die Abschaffung der oder die Senkung
der netzelte nicht mehr abbilden können
was aber weiterhin kommen wird ist die
Senkung der Stromsteuer das war Teil von
einem strompreispaket wo wir gesagt
haben für die ganz großen die sind bei
netzelden schon ausgenommen da sorgen
wir dafür dass die entlastet werden und
gleichzeitig senken wir für die Fläche
die Stromsteuer ich will aber auch mal
sagen dass an dieser großen Industrie
ich komm selbst aus dem Wahlkreis wo
sehr viele Arbeitsplätze z.B ein Bosch
dran hängen da hängt auch Mittelstand
dran da hängen auch kleinere Unternehmen
dran da einfach mal zu sagen ob die ins
Ausland gehen oder nicht ist für uns
egal und ich will auch sagen wir schauen
glaube ich alle auf ein nächstes Jahr wo
wir drei Landtagswahlen im Osten haben
wo diese Frage ob der Osten sich gerecht
behandelt fühlt ob man auch dort sagt
Transformation ist etwas was mit
Gewinnen einhergeht oder das man verlost
eine große Bedeutung hat deshalb finde
ich es absolut richtig dass wir
weiterhin sagen wir stärken den Osten
und wir sorgen dafür dass ich dort
Zukunftstechnologien anziedel so und
trotzdem sie kennen die
Wirtschaftszahlen Herr dir sie verfolgen
das genauso was die Institute da
hochrechnen für das nächste Jahr da ist
jetzt mal gerade eine Rezession für 0,3
0,4% vorausgesagt das hätte so ist die
Argumentation der Ampel noch mehr werden
können wenn es diese Investitions
Entscheidungen jetzt nicht gegeben hätte
hätte hätte Fahrradkette aber am Ende
ist natürlich wirklich die Frage ob die
Firmen diese Regierung überleben werden
also Firmen haben Corona überlebt und
Firmen haben die Finanzkrise überlebt
aber werden sie diese Regierung
überleben wenn tatsächlich weiter die
Energie und Stromkosten steigen ich
erwähnte es vor also über die die Frage
der eegumlage Abschaffung das hat diese
Koalition gemacht aber zweitens deswegen
haben wir im Deutschen Bundestag mit
Mehrheit das Wachstum chancengesetz
gchlossen deswegen haben wir gesagt
Investition in die Zukunft
Digitalisierung Klimaschutz die sollen
sich steuerlich für Unternehmen lohnen
und das ist auch unsere Antwort an der
Stelle und deswegen ärgert es mich dass
die Union es im Bundesrat auffält ich
hatte es vorhin schon gesagt ich hoffe
dass man da ich glaube sogar ganz offen
mer braun dass man da zur Einsicht
kommen wird und dass die Union das wisen
warum die Union das aufhält weil zwei
Drittel der Kosten bei den Kommunen und
Ländern landen weil und die
Mehreinnahmen am Ende auch wenn es
wirtschaftlich aufwärts geht das ist ja
nicht wir reden wir reden ja von
gemeinschaftssteuern an der stelle ich
würde mir einfach wünschen anstatt sich
immer nur abzugrenzen dass man sagt hier
ist doch ein Gesetz von dem wir doch
eigentlich alle sagen jawohl das muss
auch eine Antwort auf das sein was die
Amerikaner machen das ist durch den
Deutschen Bundestag jetzt gegangen das
führt zu mehr Investitionen mehr
Arbeitsplätzen am Ende übrigens auch aus
haushältersicht Herr Braun zu mehr
Steuereinnahmen das sollte jetzt auch
freigegeben werden das wäre mein
Weihnachtswunsch eigentlich so da sind
wir jetzt schon wenn man die Bürokratie
die in dem ganzen Gesetz steckt noch mal
deutlich entschlagt weil das ganze
bisher etwas ist wo die Unternehmen zwar
auch drauf die eine oder andere
Entlastung warten aber auch sehr
deutlich sagen das was da teilweise an
Bürokratie drin steckt geht so nicht und
sie haben das Gesetz durch den Deutschen
Bundestag gebracht ohne mit den Ländern
mal darüber zu reden wie das mit den
Kosten ist und das ist besweren sich die
Unternehmen bei ihnen her ja
selbstverständlich die beschweren sich
aber auch dass das nicht kommt und dass
ihr am Ende ein Gesetz kommt ein
wachstumschancengesetz ist gar keine
Frage das ist gut zu so die Tatsache
dass es eigentlich im Volumen her sogar
eher klein ist sage ich auch als
Haushälter also dass dass das sozusagen
unsere Wirtschaft jetzt rettet glaube
ich leider angesichts eines Volumens von
gerade mal 6 Milliarden nicht aber es
sind natürlich richtige Schritte drin
aber es sind auch Dinge drin wo man
wirklich sagen muss das hat jetzt mit
Verstärkung n zu T oder rechnen Sie mit
einer des wird es natürlich im
Vermittlungsausschuss wenn wir jetzt mal
über die Finanzlage des Jahres 24
Klarheit haben und wenn Bund und Länder
sich da verständigen wird es am Ende
natürlich eine Stärkung unserer
Wirtschaft geben aber das Ganze wenn man
wieder so wie eben gesagt den
Gesamtblick betrachtet äh die die
Aufgabe ist deutlich größer und wenn wir
z.B wie das eben angeklungen ist bei der
Energiewende weiterhin so hohe
Energiepreise haben kein Klima und
transformationsfond der Erde keine
staatliche Subvention kann so groß sein
dass wir dauerhaft als Industrieland mit
so hohen Energiepreisen überleben müen
angoten
ja die Solarindustrie zurück unter der
Union SP große Koal solarzuschüsse
streichen noch nicht die Solar Zuschüsse
und fragen uns warum sind die
Energiekosten in Deutschland so
exorbitant hoch aber fragen vorher
vielleicht Christina Dunz noch mal ganz
kurz die Bürger wollten ja dringend
wissen was kommt auf sie zu in 24 und
was kommt auf die Wirtschaft zu in 24
und jetzt wissen sie es es wird teurer
ist das die
Konklusion das ist das was ankommt ich
habe muss allerdings sagen ich glaube
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger noch
nicht so genau wissen was eigentlich
kommt weil die Kommunikationsstrategie
gestern nicht die Beste war wir kleckern
jetzt so ein bisschen hinterher was
bedeutet ähm äh was bedeuten
Einzelheiten sie haben gesagt Herr Braun
sie haben noch gar nicht wirklich eine
klare Übersicht das ist jetzt auch dem
ganzen Zeitdruck geschuldet dass man das
alles schnell machen wollte der
Bundeskanzler wollte nach zum EU-Gipfel
nach Brüssel fliegen trotzdem ist so
dies ausgeruhte was ganz am Anfang der
Koalition war als Herr Scholz sich nach
dem russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
in den Bundestag gestellt hat und von
einer Zeitenwende gesprochen hat einen
großen Wurf mit dem 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
gemacht hat das ist wonach eine
Bevölkerung sich sehnt das Ruhe
vermittelt wird dass der Eindruck
vermittelt wird wir wissen was wir tun
wir haben das in der Hand und wir führen
euch dadurch und heute gestern Morgen
konnte man wieder so den Eindruck haben
m irgendwie kriegen wir das hin herr
Scholz hat das mit der mit dem
überschreitensbeschluss gesagt und hat
deutlich gemacht wir werden das bei der
Flutkatastrophe im Aal anwenden Herr
Lindner stellt sich unmittelbar also
Minuten danach hin und sagt in derselben
im selben Pressestatement wir prüfen das
und so kommt wieder der Eindruck der
Verwirrung und es ist ja ganz schnell äh
wieder in diesen Modus gekommen äh dass
SPD Grüne und FDP unter den Beschlüssen
was anderes verstehen und was anderes
wollen und ähm sie ich meine sie
bekommen keine Ruhe da rein und wenn man
sagt wer zahlt eigentlich für die
Beschlüsse würde ich es etwas größer
fassen und sagen die Demokratie und der
klimaähchutz das eine ist nicht diese
Ruhe zu vermitteln sie haben die
Landtagswahlen im nächsten Jahr in
Thüring Sachsen und Brandenburg
angesprochen die AFD liegt an erster
Stelle ähm auch wenn sie keine
Alleinregierung schafft was durchaus in
Thüringen und Sachsen gar nicht
ausgeschlossen ist wenn Sie schon den
Landtagspräsidenten stellt äh ist sie
für den wissenschaftlichen Dienst
verantwortlich sie ist für die
Verwaltung verantwortlich sie wird äh es
ist dieses reingreifen in die Demokratie
und
aus dem Osten sagen mir von den drei
ampelparteien Abgeordnete dass sie es
nicht mehr schultern können dass immer
noch was oben drauf aufkmt und keine
Ruhe reinkommt und sie können sich
vorstellen wo das Signal einzahlt heizen
tanken Strom wird teurer aber darf ich
dazu zu der Frage Demokratie und Klima
also einmal bei der Demokratie ich
glaube auch dass jetzt Zeit ist für Ruhe
und das haben wir auch nicht gut
hinbekommen als Ampel letzten Wochen das
kann man ehrlich so sagen das tut mir
auch Leid und das jetzt Zeit für
Stabilität ist wenn Sie aber auch sagen
dass der Klimaschutz verliert das sehe
ichag wirklich nicht die großen Projekte
aus KTF es gibt da auch z.B Fälle wie
bei der Bahn das wird nicht mehr weiter
aus KTF finanziert sondern über eine
eigenkapitaldeckung da fließen aber die
Gelder weiter wisen ob sie Telekom oder
Post verkaufen das wird in die schiine
investiert werden das heißt die großen
Projekte aus dem KTF gehen weiter und
gleichzeitig bauen wir klimaschädliche
Subventionen ab z.B eine kerossinsteuer
z.B eine Luftverkehrsabgabe das heißt
klimaschädliche Subventionen werden
abgebaut und das Geld wird genommen um
wiederum in neue Technologien in
klimafreundliche Technologien und
Arbeitsplätze zu investieren ich sehe
nicht dass der Klimaschutz da gewonnen
hat sondern das ist sogar ein
Fortschritt beim Klimaschutz der in den
letzten zwei Jahren so nicht möglich war
okay wir fragen noch mal hermann Josef
Tenhagen genau nach diesem Effekt
überall in der Welt wird es diese
transition geben diese Transformation
geben in der Wirtschaft und natürlich
bemüht sich jedes Land auch jeder
Kontinent da den besten Weg zu finden
haben wir einen so falschen oder einen
so komplizierten kann man klüger
initiieren und
unterstützen etwas wir sind nicht immer
besonders clever wir haben also bei der
Solarindustrie wir haben eine tolle
Solarindustrie aufgebaut und dann haben
wir die verhungern lassen und die
Chinesen haben es weitergebrachtt wir
haben bei der Automobilindustrie drauf
warten müssen dass die Chinesen gesagt
haben wir brauchen ein Drittel E-Autos
sonst braucht ihr in China nicht mehr
anzutreten und dann sind die deutschen
Konzerne auch auf den Gedanken gekommen
dass man E-Autos bauen könnte also da
sind da sind wir nicht besonders gut
gewesen und da kann man deutlich besser
sein und bis und diese e-autou Umlage
oder die Unterstützung gerade auslaufen
lassen das he kann man auch auslaufen
lassen weil die Autos sind viel zu teuer
also das das kann man preiswerter machen
die müssen auch preiswerter werden weil
die Chinesen nämlich auf dem Markt
kommen das gibt gar SP man natürlich
auch Steuergelder da ist der Bürger am
Ende eigentlich auch einfach es gibt ja
immer noch diese hohen Subventionen für
die Wärme Heiz also für die
Wärmepumpen das läuft jetzt praktisch
parallel zu der CO2 Preiserhöhung die
die Menschen natürlich auch motivieren
wird zu gucken ob man nicht überhaupt
eine neue Energie und energetische
Versorgung also ist es klug was wir da
machen oder einfach auch viel zu
kompliziiert ne das ist ist einfach also
leider muss der oder die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger müssen einfach viel mehr selbst
machen ich mache das jetzt mal am
Beispiel was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
machen können also im Augenblick ist es
so dass durchschnittlich der Strompreis
bei 45 Cent lit 44 Cent wenn sie neuen
Stromvertrag abschließen bezahlen Sie 32
ob die Regierung mit irgendeiner
Maßnahme 3 C drauf liegt dann sind sie
von 32 bei 35 machen sie das suchen Sie
sich den preiswerteren Vertrag das beim
Gas ist der durch Preis im augenblck 14
Cent sie können 9 Cent bezahlen wenn die
wenn da eine halbe Cent drauf kommt
durch die CO2 ABL machen sie das
wechseln Sie ich sag immer bei uns kann
man Finanz kann man nachgucken wechseln
Sie einfach das schlimmste ist das
schlimm und das ein wirkliches Problem
ist Fernwärme da liegt der
Durchschnittspreis heute bei 15 18 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde also ausgerechnet das
was wir über und da könen die Leute
nicht wechseln weil nämlich das ist ein
Monopolist und das ist häuflich auch
noch ein staatlicher Monopolist das sind
Kommunen die die stad wke da da gibt's
ein riesen Problem im Januar
prognostiziere ich ihn Gas kann man
wechseln Strom kann man wechseln beim
Sprit kann man gucken dass man weniger
Auto fährt und spritparen da fährt gibt
schöne Videos vom ADAC wie 2 Liter
weniger pro 100 km brauchen wenn sie
vernünftig autoofahren machen sie das
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger weil das
werden sie tun sie können nicht darauf
rechnen dass in der kurzen Frist in
dieser dieser Ampel oder auch die
Opposition die hat da auch sich nicht
mit Rum und trotzdem jetzt noch mal
zurück zu der Frage auch die Industrie
treffend ist es denn gut so zu
subventionieren und so zu unterstützen
wie die Regierung das jetzt plant wenn
es parallel dazu eben immer neue ähm
Auflagen gibt und immer neue
Einschränkungen gibt also ich ich glaube
da muss man immer genau hingucken dass
man das genau nicht so macht im
Einzelfall ne nicht auf der einen Seite
subventionieren auf der anderen Seite
die die Handbremse ziehen weil das
funktioniert nicht aber das ist ehrlich
gesagt äh das Terrain der beiden äh und
nicht des verbraucherschüzes so und dann
ist man Herr auch noch auf die Idee
gekommen zu sagen dass eben unbedingt
1,5 Milliarden auch daraus kommen sollen
dass die Ukrainer jetzt mehr arbeiten in
Deutschland damit eben nicht mehr 17%
sondern 70% der Ukrainer wie das in
Tschechien gelingt hier in Arbeit sind
aber ist denn auch das wir kommen auf
die haushalterischen Fragen zurück eine
berechenbare Größe oder ist es nicht
eher ein politisches Ziel dass sie sich
wünschen dass weil wir die rahbedingung
die Strukturen richtigerweise ändern es
geht nicht dass in Deutschland 20% der
Ukrainer Ukrainer nur die Möglichkeit
haben zu arbeiten anderen Ländern 50 und
70% sie haben es gerade erwähnt Frau ner
deswegen hat der Arbeitsminister zurecht
gesagt mit einem Jobmotor für die
Ukrainer kriegen wir besseres hin allein
indem wir Auflagen reduzieren dass ein
Sprachkurs nicht mittags um 12 Uhr
stattfindet sondern vielleicht nach
Feierabend so hat jemand die Möglichkeit
eine Arbeitsaufnahme zu machen ganz
pragmatische Lösung und übrigens das
gleiche in der Energiepolitik diese
Koalition hat hinbekommen die
planungsbeschleunigung auf den Weg zu
bringen
Erne
dasorungh Jahre diskutiert und nichts
ist passiert also wir ändern ja genau
das dass man nicht alles in zwei Jahren
ändert ärgert mich manchmal auch aber
vieles haben wir dazu geschafft und dann
kam natürlich eine
energiekrisensituation wegen der krassen
Abhängigkeit Deutschlands von russischem
Erdgas dazu mit dem muss man zurecht
kommen als Regierung das ist unsere
Verantwortung ich will mich da gar nicht
da gar nicht beschweren an der Stelle
aber deswegen waren die preisbremsen
auch nötig jetzt ist die Preissituation
her t hat zurecht gesagt besser geworden
deswegen kann ich mich dem Appell die
Marktwirtschaft zu nutzen nur
anschließen und den Anbieter
beispielsweise zu wechseln weil man Geld
spart weil die Rahmenbedingungen jetzt
besser geworden sind also wir ändern was
an diesen Rahmenbedingung das dauert
manchmal ein bisschen aber zumindestens
hat diese Regierung diese Reform
angefangen die vorher so lange
diskutiert worden sind aber wenn ich zu
dem tomotor mal einen Satz sagen darf
weil das das muss ich sagen das finde
ich wirklich nicht in Ordnung also wir
haben 4 Millionen Menschen die
arbeitsfähig sind und im Bürgergeld sind
und wenn wir jetzt versuchen und wenn
wir wenn wir 500.000 von
denen wenn wenn wir 500000 in Arbeit
brechen dann hätten wir ungefähr 15
Milliarden Euro an Einsparung das heißt
das wäre ein riesenprjekt aber das was
hier passiert ist den Jobmotor gab es
schon vor dem Verfassungsgerichtsurteil
der Jobmotor ist schon in im Haushalt
eingepreist gewesen man hat sich jetzt
nur in der Nacht der Einigung überlegt
dass man den Jobmotor ohne dass man an
ihm Struktur was ändert noch anderthalb
Milliarden mehr einsparen kann damit ist
es eine geschätzte luftbuchung und das
haben wir in diesem Jahr gesehen wir
haben in diesem Jahr hat die Regierung
die z.B die Grundsicherung im Alter auch
völlig unterschätzt was passiert dann
wir kriegen eine Mitteilung vom
vanzministerium dass wir 800 Millionen
mehr ausgeben zur Kenntnisnahme weil es
eine gesetzliche Leistung ist und da
kann man gar nichts mehr dran ändern
also wenn man sagt da wollen wir noch
mehr sparen im Sinne von wir bringen
noch mehr Leute in Arbeit da muss man
das auch noch mit zusätzlichen Maßnahmen
unterlegen und das wäre ja die Hoffnung
gewesen dass dass man sich auf etwas
einigt was nicht nur in der Größe von 10
20 30.000 mal die dass man sich mal vor
die Presse tritt und sagt wir haben eine
Idee wie wir eine halbe Million Menschen
mehr in Arbeit bringen das wäre mal
wumps gewesen hat das will ich aber
sagen nichts mit dem Bürgergeld zu tun
das Problem was Sie beschreiben und ich
bin gar nicht so weit entfernt gab es be
Hatz 4 ganz genauso ja ich wünsche mir
mehr Erwerbsbeteiligung gar keine Frage
und da muss man auch drüber reden
beispielsweise hat der Arbeitsminister
jetzt eine Studie zu arbeitsanreizen
Auftrag beim ifo Institut was ich mit
fantastischen Ergebnissen sehe nämlich
zu sagen wie schaffen wir es dass
Menschen beispielsweise durch Teilzeit
sich aus dem Bürgergeld früher hat viel
herausarbeitet indem es attraktiver ist
eine Teilzeitstelle anzunehmen auch an
der Stelle sind wir unterwegs Verl das
hat nicht braun das hat nichts mit dem
Bürgergeld zu tun das Dilemma hatte die
große Koalition auch schon jetzt fangen
was an indem wir die Arbeitsanreize
Stärken jetzt stärken wir Arbeitsanreize
das ist auch bei Harz 4 damals noch
gemacht worden sie merken liebe
Zuschauer es gibt viel zu ordnen und
viel zu verstehen weil eine Lösung
dieses haushaltsentscheides dieses
Kompromisses darin bestand möglichst
ganz viele Dinge in diesen Kompromiss zu
schreiben die Geld einsparen sollen wir
haben zu Beginn der Sendung auch schon
über einen Kniff des Bundeskanzlers
gesprochen wie er vielleicht eine Tür
noch mal öffnen könnte um in Bezug auf
diesen dramatischen Krieg den Putin
gegen die Ukraine führt ähm mehr Geld zu
ermöglichen für diese Regierung sollten
mehr Waffen mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung für die Verteidigung
notwendig sein und hier ist die
entscheidende Frage dürfte er das
überhaupt das bereden wir jetzt nicht in
unserem erlauchten Kornkreis hier
sondern Fragen in Frankfurt Sara Tacke
die Rechtsexpertin des zweiten deutschen
Fernsehens SAR genau diese entscheidende
Frage sollte sich die Lage
verschlechtern sagt der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz dann würde man diesen
überschreitensbeschluss in 24 machen
können ist das vorstellbar in ihren
Augen da gibt's eine klassische
juristenantwort von mir es kommt darauf
an super genau es ich werde aber gleich
konkret es kommt darauf an wieso er die
Überschreitung was ja nur ein anderes
Wort für Notsituation ist begründet ja
ob ob er sagt dass es
notwendig ist
weil wir wirklich eine neue Lage haben
also weil der ukrainekrieg
weil wir eine neue Situation haben dass
beispielsweise Verbündete aus dem Krieg
austreten und Deutschland stärker
gefordert ist dann haben wir ganz klar
eine neue Notsituation die das auch
begründen würde wenn wir aber sagen wir
haben einfach eine vordauer des Krieges
dann haben wir ist es keine ganz leichte
Begründung und das hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht auch konkret
vorgegeben weil in dem Urteil ganz klar
zu lesen ist je länger die die
auslösende Notsituation also der
Kriegsausbruch her ist das war 2022 im
Februar bald zi Jahre her desto höher
ist die
begründungsbedürftigkeit wenn man in den
Folgejahren sagt wir haben immer noch
eine Notsituation das heißt unterm
schich kann man sagen es kommt darauf an
wieso diese Notsituation ausgerufen wird
und wie sie begründet wird man könnte
jetzt wieder politisch diskutieren dass
die Nachrichtenlage allein der letzten
zwei Tage befürchten lässt dass dieser
Krieg noch sehr lange dauern wird und
dass Wladimir Putin auch nicht aufhören
wird äh die umliegenden Nachbar Staaten
zu ähm überfallen und zu quellen ähm das
ist dann tatsächlich auch eine
juristische Frage oder nicht schon
wieder eine politische ob dafür dann
mehr Geld nötig ist nee es ist immer
eine politische state Frage weil die
Politik niemals gezwungen ist eine
Notsituation auszurufen wenn sie sagen
sie können es vom normalen Haushalt
bezahlen dann können Sie das tun also es
ist eine politische Frage die Frage ist
nur ob sie juristisch hält und da kommt
einfach drauf an wie sie begründet wird
und ähm und wieso sie ausgerufen wird
also haben wir wirklich eine neue Lage
und wenn wir keine entscheidend neue
Lage haben kommt es darauf an wie man
begründet dass die Folgen dieses
Kriegsausbruch immer noch ein höheren
Finanzbedarf erfordern als man mit einem
normalen Haushalt bezahlen könnte jetzt
haben wir schon besprochen in den
letzten 55 Minuten wie viele Dinge die
Ampel eben gerne in Angriff nehmen
möchte und immer schwang dieses Damokles
Schwert über den Verständigungen ob das
rechtsfest ist Verfassung kform und
recht sicher ist was da beschlossen wird
was würden Sie sagen ich würde sagen ja
es ist verfassungskonform und restfest
rechtsfest alle Beschlüsse die ich
soweit kenne mit einer entscheidenden
Ausnahme und die hatte Herr Brauen
direkt zu Beginn der Sendung
angesprochen der Sonderfond fürs artal
und da haben wir eine Sondersituation
grundsätzlich muss man sagen die
Flutkatastrophe 2021 im
Atal steht sogar im Grundgesetz ist der
klassische Fall einer Notsituation ein
unvorhersehbares Ereignis wo man mit
einem Sondervermögen reingehen kann aber
2021 liegt jetzt auch dann bald dre
Jahre zurück muss man natürlich jetzt
noch mal begründeeit höher schrauben
wieso man immer noch Sondervermögen
braucht aber wer im Atal kürzlich war
sieht dass der Wiederaufbau enorm dauert
dass die Menschen Vorort extrem
gefordert sind das heißt das andauernd
der folgen würde niemand absprechen aber
und das jetzt kommt worauf Herr Braun
hinausfollte jetzt stehen da 2,6 2,7
Milliarden fürs nächste jah das ist
nicht viel hat Herr Lindner schon mal
gesagt daran scheitern wir nicht viel
daran scheitern wir nicht im Vergleich
zum Gesamthaushalt und genauso kann man
das auch sehen man kann man kann sagen
es ist eben nicht die die erhebliche
Belastung des des des Haushalts aber man
kann es auch anders sehen man kann auch
sagen diese Flutkatastrophe kostet uns
über die Jahre 15 16 17 Milliarden und
nur weil wir sie jedes Jahr gesondert
verbuchen kann das nicht zum Nachteil
sein man muss aber ganz klar sagen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich dazu
in seinem Urteil nicht geäußert man kann
das nicht aus dem Urteil herauslesen was
aber klar ist die Chance für die CDU
wenn Sie dagegen klagt vor Gericht sind
maximal
5050 und der politische Schaden ist
natürlich enorm nicht nur wenn man
scheitert sondern überhaupt dies
Sondervermögen und und und die
Unterstützung der Menschen im Al
anzugreifen ist natürlich
politisch mutig würde ich mal sagen so
dann haben wir auch noch festgestellt
und wollen unbedingt diese Frage noch
loswerden der Bundesfinanzminister sagt
SAR Tacke unablässig dass wir eigentlich
genug Geld haben dass Deutschland genug
Geld hat und dass wir es besser schlauer
einsetzen müssen das sagt die Union auch
aber innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
eigentlich nur der Finanzminister
ähm schafft er damit nicht auch ein
Argument eigentlich nie eine Notlage
entstehen zu
lassen ja könnte man meinen aber nicht
zwingend man muss sich das vorstellen
wie zwei Kassen wenn man den normalen
Haushalt hat mit dem man den Alltag
bestreitet und dann eine
außergewöhnliche Notsituation kommt
heißt das nicht und das hat das Gericht
auch ganz klar gesagt dass man diese
Notsituation aus der Haushaltskasse
zahlen muss man kann es ist wieder eine
politische Entscheidung wenn man das
will kann man das machen man muss es
aber nicht das heißt wenn wir eine
Notsituation gegeben haben die den
Haushalt außergewöhnlich belastet dann
kann diese zweite Sonderkasse aufgemacht
werden auch wenn die Haus Kasse gut
gefüllt ist ja und damit danken wir für
diese Erklärung das war wie immer
erhellend ganz herzlichen Dank nach
Frankfurt zu SAR Tacke und wir sind
Christina Dunz schon wieder bei dieser
ampelregierung und fragen uns worüber
wird sie sich als nächstes streiten oder
denken Sie dass das Bestand haben wird
also als nächstes wird sie sich über die
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse streiten
weil das ist ja das steht ja noch bevor
der Bundeskanzler hat es angekündigt der
Finanzminister hat widersprochen und ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt dieses
Unverständnis nicht die Ukraine nicht
als Notlage zu begreifen und zwar jeden
Tag weiter wir sehen was da passiert die
Russen werden nicht mit der groß offenen
großen Gegenoffensive der Ukraine
zurückgedrängt wir wissen was das für
Europa bedeutet wenn Putin nicht Einhalt
gegeben wird und wir tun da oder sie die
Ampel
und vor allem die FDP tut da so dass das
äh also Sie können ja auch viel mehr
eine Notlage schon mal klären begründen
kommunizieren das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat übrigens
einen ganz deutlich einen Ermessens und
Beurteilungsspielraum für die Politik
aufgezeigt quasi so aus schlechten
Gewissen was man ihnen mit dem Urteil Z
zugemutet hat dass sie das sehr können
und das zweite ist auch eine politische
Frage der Klimawandel wir wissen der
Meeresspiegel steigt das Eis in der
Antarktis schmilzt es ist wir werden in
Notlagen kommen sich auch dem zu
verschließen und nicht mit vorzubereiten
was auf dieses Land zukommt und dann
sage ich mal die Augen zu verdrehen so
als wenn das nicht wirklich die
tragenden Themen für diese Ampel sind da
bin ich wirklich erstaunt ich bin exakt
ich bin exakt bei Frau Tack und
gegenteiliger Auffassung als Frau Dunz
denn das was Sie beschreiben ist die
Realität des Jahres 2023 und mutmaßig
die Realität der kommenden Jahre und das
neue normal aber deswegen kann man aber
deswegen kann man doch nicht sagen wenn
ich das nur kurz wenn ich da nur kurz
einführen selbstverständlich aber
deswegen kann man sich doch nicht daran
gewöhnen wenn jeden Tag etwas schlimmer
wird es wird jeden Tag das ist jetzt
moralis auflag die ich gar nicht gemeint
habe und die auch nicht herausverstanden
hätte werden können dass das furchtbar
ist ist doch gar keine Frage die Frage
ist wie man haushalterisch und mit dem
Ziel der Stabilität damit umgeht und zu
sagen etwas ist schrecklich heißt ja
nicht dass man finanzpolitische
Instrumente nutzt die unter Umständen
und sind andere Schwierigkeit
stchuldenkise ist gerade Jahre her
damals hatte sich Europa halsüber Kopf
verschuldet und wir war einer
dramatischen Situation ein Grund warum
Europa stabil ist ist weil Deutschland
stabil ist und deswegen muss man für die
zukun und für die Zukunft für
Klimawandel beispielsweise aber
insbesondere auch für mögliche
Kriegssituation gewappnet sein also wer
jetzt ruft das tun sie das tun viele CDU
Ministerpräsidenten wir sollten einfach
immer mehr Schulden machen dem rate ich
davon ab wir sollten auch vorbereitet
sein auf mögliche Schocksituation der
Krieg ist furchtbar leider wird er
werden solche Situation auch
geopolitische herausfordernd Situation
wir sehen es bedauerlicherweise im Nahen
Osten auch zur Realität könen deswegen
müssen wir haushalterisch damit umgehen
einfach nur zu sagen sobald etwas
schlimm ist und Furchtbares passiert
rufen wir immer Notlagen aus halte ich
stabilitätspolitisch für eine absolut
falsche Ansage und will noch mal eins
hinzufügen ne nein den Einsatz muss ich
schon sagen den Einsatz muss ich schon
sagen dürfen Frau inner dass das auch
aus zeigt die Schuldenquote 70% zur
Zeiten der großen Koalition wir gehen
jetzt auf unter 65% zurück also wir
wollen diese Stabilität ganz ganz kurz
ich ich sag einfach nur ein Wort Steuern
in
steuerland ich sag nur wenn ein Haushalt
sozusagen da ist dann hat man zwei
Möglichkeiten Gegenteil entlasten ja wir
reduzieren ste exakt sie entlasten
gerade da kann man kann man auch drüber
nachdenken ob das vernünftig ist aber
natürlich hat ein Staat neben der
Notlage neben der Notlage auch immer die
Möglichkeit zu sagen äh sozusagen wir
brauchen mehr Geld um ums mit der
klimaherausforderung um uns mit der
Ukraine auseinanderzusetzen oder kann
man mit den Leuten so und die Diskussion
muss man bitte einfach mitführen und man
muss eben sagen wir wollen wir wollen
das nicht tun oder man will das
vielleicht doch tun oder man will das
erklären oder nicht erklären weil zum
Teil sind das ja jetzt im Augenblick
Sachen die nicht erklärt worden sind und
dann hat man die diese diese diese
plastikabgabe auf einmal aus der aus dem
Hut gezaubert wo ich z.B nicht mal
wusste dass wir aus dem aus dem
Steuersäckel etwas bezahlen weil wir
diese Plastik Geschichten aus der EU die
Regelungen die uns aufgetragen sind die
wir mitbeschlossen haben in der EU dass
wir die nicht umgesetzt haben das ist
doch das ist doch ein bisschen Chimäre
und da wäre ich dafür doch ein bisschen
klarer den Leuten zu sagen wenn das was
kostet wenn Klima was kosten wird wenn
die Ukraine uns was kosten wird dann
gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten entweder wir
bauen den so alst ab soll doch einer
sagen wir bauen den sozialstat ab weil
wir das für die Ukraine brauchen oder
wir bauen den ab weil wir sonst den
klimawandell man kann kanvention
reduzieren und prioritten ist bei der
FDP ich wollte gerade schon sagen ich
schaff leider anders als Tenhagen nicht
in einem Wort aber sie haben zum Glck
auch mehr gesagt nein ich würde
tatsächlich einmal unterscheiden ich
finde bei der Klimakrise können wir
tatsächlich nicht dauerhaft jedes Jahr
mit einer neuen Notlage argumentieren da
setzt das bundesverfassungsricht auch
relativ enge Grenzen s da brauchen wir
aus meiner Sicht tatsächlich eine Reform
der schulldenbremse denn wir haben auch
ein anderes Urteil aus karlsroh aus 2021
wo klar gesagt wird Klimaschutz ist
verfassungsmäßig Auftrag da ist die
Freiheitsrechte zukünftig generations
sichert und würde ich sagen da wo wir in
Klimaschutz investieren investieren wir
in die Freiheit zukünftige Generation
und sollten deshalb eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse machen mit einer
investitionsklausel jetzt bei der
Ukraine und wir haben ganz klar gesagt
wir stehen an der Seite der Ukraine wir
geben diese Gelder weit wir unterstützen
militärisch finanziell humanitär wenn
eine neue Situation ent steht und das
kann tatsächlich passieren es wurde
gerade ein Beispiel genannt wenn die
US-Amerikaner sich zurückziehen was
dramatisch wäre aus meiner Sicht für die
geopolitische Lage aber wenn das
passieren sollte dann werden wir handeln
und dann werden wir finanzieren dann
werden wir auch die Notlage ausrufen
denn am Ende ist klar es entscheidet
sich im jetzigen Moment od das will muss
man glaub ich schon der ernsthit
Ernsthaftigkeit klar haben es
entscheidet sich gerade auch wie sich
Demokratien im internationalen
systemwettbewerb behaupten es
entscheidet sich die europäis
Sicherheitsarchitektur und hier wenn ich
ein schönes Signal vielleicht auch von
diesem heutigen Tag nennen darf dass auf
dem EU-Gipfel der Weg endlich
freigemacht wurde dass die Ukraine die
Europäische Union beigetreten hat ein
wahnsinnig starkes Signal das auch zeigt
wir stehen weiter an eurer Seite und um
jetzt aber ganz kurz noch mal
zurückzukommen wenn das alles so wäre in
Bezug auf die Ukraine würden wir uns das
natürlich nicht wünschen und natürlich
müsste ein Staat und müsste Europa
reagieren dann wüssten sie Frau lang
aber schon dass die FDP wieder
protestiert und dass sie dann diese
Koalition aufkündigen oder machen Sie
dann wieder weiter weil sie einen
überschreitensbeschluss wir haben uns
geeinigt wir finanzieren es jetzt aus
dem Haushalt wir sehen gerade keine
Notlage mit Blick auf die Ukraine wenn
sich die Situation verändert werden wir
handeln dann gibt es auch die
Möglichkeit von dem 115 als eine Notlage
auszurufen und wir werden die Koalition
dann nicht verlassen ich glaube auch
dass unser Partner nicht tun wird denn
wir müssen mal ein bisschen schauen es
hat ein letzten Monaten eine gewisse
noral la eingezogen in Deutschland mit
Neuwahlen zu spielen ich glaube dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich Sicherheit
wünschen sich Stabilität wünschen könen
wir besser
wer eiglich zentrale Frage ob sie beide
haben wir heute hier das Gefühl ob sie
also ob diese drei Partner es noch
miteinander aushalten und in welchem
krisenmodus das ist das Wort des Jahres
V uns krisenmodus ob die Ampel ihren
krisenmodus gefunden haben ist der
Bundeskanzler mit 18% Anerkennung durch
die Menschen in diesem Land die nächsten
zwei Jahre noch im Amt
ja also ähm ja wür ich auchagen die die
wenn man davon ausgehen geht was für
alle drei Parteien zutrifft im Falle
einer Neuwahl würde nichts für sie
bleiben wie es ist die FDP würde
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr in den
Bundestag kommen herr Scholz hätte große
Probleme wieder Kanzler zu werden und
die Grünen werden unter Umständen nicht
in der Regierung das hält sie natürlich
sehr zusammen ich bin mir nicht sicher
wie Herr Lindner reagieren wird wenn das
Mitgliedervotum der Partei kommt die
Koalition zu verlassen sollte es so
kommen und wenn er beim Aussetzen der
Schuldenbremse dann doch in die in die
Situation kommt zupringen aber was die
FDP ja am liebsten hätte wäre ohne
Neuwahl in die Opposition zu kommen da
könnten sie sich wieder etwas Stärken
dann werden wir wieder bei der Union
dann werden wir wieder bei der Union die
es aber schwer haben würde jetzt mit
doppelt so viel einer Prognose wie sie
da stehen würde in diese Regierung
einzutreten
das Gesamtbild ist dass mit der
Ampelkoalition eine Verunsicherung des
Landes den großen Knacks hat sie beim
heizungsgesetz bekommen dar steht und
dass auch dieser
Entscheid nicht den Aufbruch vermittelt
und nicht wir gehen jetzt in in sicheres
Fahrwasser und die Alternative wenn ich
das noch kurz sagen darf dass der
cduchef Friedrich März Kanzlerkandidat
würde trägt glaube ich nicht zur
Beruhigung in die diesem Land bei weil
wir sehen wie er agiert im Bundestag wie
er immer wieder erklärt werden muss wenn
er Sachen erzählt hat die einen erstmal
auf die Palme bringen klemtner einen
ganzen Berufsstand sozusagen in Verruf
bringt oder von kleinen Paschas oder
sozialturismus spricht und so weiter
insofern ist die Lage des Landes ähm
eher
ähm bedrückt also ich will Fried ich
Merz nicht verteidigen aber zu sagen
Herr märz kann es nicht Herr Scholz kann
es nicht das finde ich zu wenig offen
gestanden es geht jetzt um nein es geht
aber Frau dun ganz offen ja aber das
finde ich auch auch zu einfach sowohl
der Opposition als auch der
regierungsmeh abzusprechen dass sie es
können das teile ich nämlich nicht wir
sind in unfassbar herausfordernden
Zeiten Frau Dunz wir sind sehr
konzentriert am Arbeit ich unterstelle
das übrigens auch durchaus der Union
beer Kritik auch an Friedrich Merz und
an der Politik und auch der
ministerpr wir sind in einer schwierigen
Situation jetzt haben wir Stabilität in
den Haushalt gebracht und ich finde dann
kann man auch mal sagen jawohl wir
schauen ins neue Jahr wenn wir dann noch
das Wachstum chancengesetz sind bekmen
dann find n nenen sie es selbst einen
Kompromiss der da gefunden ist beim
Haushalt sprchen ja nicht von sind schon
wieder total dagegen ich mE über eine
Gruppe noch gar nicht gesprochen die
Landwirte verlieren ihre ihre
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und der
Landwirtschaftsminister hat von der
ganzen Einigung nichts mitgekriegt dies
Reg
gr ein guter Moment um einen Punkt zu
setzen würde ich sagen ich darf mich
bedanken für die Diskussion es ist die
letzte Sendung unsere letzte Sendung in
diesem Jahr wir sehen uns so sie mögen
am 11 Januar 24 wieder und bis dahin
haben Sie hoffentlich eine einigermaßen
gute Zeit kommen gut übers Jahr bis zum
111 2024 tschüss alles Liebe vielen Dank
noch mal und jetzt eine gute Nacht
Markus Lanz hat unter anderem Elma
tebesen zu Gast und das reicht als
kliffhänger das ist einer der besten
Washington Korrespondenten der Welt
[Musik]
tschü